do you think let's look at vladimir
putin specifically
do you think
he's
getting accurate information about the
world do you think he knows the truth of
the world whether that's the war in
ukraine whether that's the behavior of
the other nations in nato the united
states in general what do you think
it's rare that i'll talk about just
thinking it's i prefer to share
my assessment why i assess things a
certain way rather than just what's my
random opinion
in my assessment vladimir putin is
winning
russia is winning they're winning in
ukraine but they're also winning the
battle of influence against the west
they're winning in the face of economic
sanctions they're winning
empirically when you look at the math
they're winning
so
when you ask me whether or not putin is
getting good information from
intelligence services when i look at my
overall assessment of multiple data
points he must be getting good
information do i know how or why i do
not i don't know how or why it works
there i don't know how such
deep cronyism such deep
corruption can possibly yield true real
results and yet somehow there are real
results happening so it's either
excessive waste and an accidental win or
there really is a system and a process
there that's functioning so this winning
idea is very interesting in what way
short term and long term is russia
winning some people say there was a
miscalculation of the way the invasion
happened
uh there was an assumption that you
would be able to successfully take care
of
you you'd be able to successfully
capture the east the south and the north
of ukraine
and with
what now appears to be significantly
insufficient troops spread way too thin
across way too large of a front
so that seems to be like an intelligence
failure
and uh and that doesn't seem to be like
winning
in another way it doesn't seem like
winning if we put aside the human cost
of war
it doesn't seem like winning
because the hearts and minds of the west
were completely on the side of ukraine
this particular leader in vladimir
zelinski captured the attention of the
world and the hearts and minds of europe
the west
and many other nations throughout the
world both financially in terms of
military equipment and in terms of
sort of
social and cultural and emotional
support for the independence fight of
this nation that seems to be like a
miscalculation
so
against
that pushback why do you think there's
still
colonels of
winning in this on the russian side
what you're laying out isn't incorrect
and
the miscalculations are not
unexpected anybody who's been to a
military college including the army war
college in pennsylvania where so many of
our military leaders
are brought up
when you
look at the conflict in ukraine it fits
the exact mold of what an effective
long-term military conflict protracted
military conflict would and should look
like for military dominance
now did zielinski and did the did the
ukrainians shock the world absolutely
but in that they also shocked american
intelligence which like you said
miscalculated the whole world
miscalculated how the ukrainians would
respond putin did not move in there
accidentally he had an assessment he had
high likelihood of a certain outcome and
that outcome did not happen
why did he have that calculation because
in 2014 it worked
he invaded uh he took crimea in 14 days
he basically created
a
an infiltration campaign that turned key
leaders over in the first few days of
the conflict
so essentially there was no conflict it
worked in 2008 when he took georgia
nobody talks about that
he invaded georgia the exact same same
way and it worked so in 2008 it worked
in 2014 it worked there was no reason to
believe it wasn't going to work again
so he just carried out the same campaign
but this time something was different
that was a miscalculation for sure on
the part of putin and the reason that
there was no support from the west
because let's not forget there is no
support there is nothing other than the
lend lease act
which is putting ukraine in massive debt
right now to the west
that's the only form of support they're
getting from nato or the united states
so if somebody believed ukraine would
win if somebody believed ukraine had a
chance they would have gotten more
material support than just debt and we
can jump into that anytime you want to
but the whole world miscalculated
everybody thought russia was going to
win in 14 days i i said that they would
win in 14 days because that was the
predominant calculation
once the first invasion didn't work then
the military does what professional
militaries do man they they re-evaluate
they re
reorganize leaders and then they they
take a new approach you saw three
approaches the first two did not work
the first two campaigns against ukraine
did not work the way they were supposed
to work the third has worked
exactly like it's supposed to work you
don't need kiev to win ukraine you don't
need hearts and minds to win ukraine
what do you need yeah what you need is
control of of natural resources which
they're taking in the east and you need
access to the heart beat the blood flow
of food and money into the country which
they're taking in the south
the fact that ukraine had to go to the
negotiation table
with russia and turkey
in order to get exports
out of the black sea approved again
demonstrates just how much ukraine is
losing
the the aggressor had a seat at the
negotiation table
to allow ukraine the ability to even
export one of its top exports if russia
would have said no then they would not
have had that russia has that's like
someone holding your throat it's like
somebody holding your jugular vein and
saying
if if you don't
do what i tell you to do
then i'm not gonna let you breathe i'm
not gonna let blood flow to your brain
so do you think
it's possible that russia takes the
south
of ukraine
it takes
um so starting from mariupol
the herson region
all the way to odessa all the way to
odessa and into
into uh moldova
i believe all that will happen before
the fall
fall of this year fall of this year
before winter hits europe nato
wants germany needs
to be able to have sanctions lifted so
they can tap into russian power there's
no way they can have those sanctions
lifted unless russia wins and russia
also knows
that all of europe all of nato is the
true
the true people feeling the pain of the
war outside of ukraine
are the nato countries because they're
so heavily reliant on russia
and as
they have supported american sanctions
against russia their people feel the
pain economically
their people feel the pain what are they
going to do in the winter because
without russian gas
their people are going to freeze to
death ukrainian people people all over
nato
i
ukraine
everybody knows ukraine's at risk
everybody knows ukrainians are dying
the game of war isn't played
just it isn't even played majority by
the people who are fighting the game of
war is played by everyone else it's an
economic game it's not a military game
the flow of resources and energy
attention
exactly right
i was on the front in the herson region
this very area that you're referring to
and i spoke to a lot of people and those
the morale
is incredibly high
and i don't think
the people in that region
soldiers
volunteer soldiers
civilians
are going
to give up that land without dying i
agree with you
i mean in order to take odessa
would require a
huge amount of artillery
and slaughter of civilians essentially
they're not going to use artillery
odessa because odessa is too important
to russian culture um it's going to be
even uglier than that it's going to be
clearing up streets clearing of
buildings
person by person troop by troop it'll be
a lot like what it was in marvel
just shooting at civilians because they
can't afford to just do bombing raids
because they're going to destroy
cultural
uh significant architecture that's just
too important to the russian culture and
that's going to demoralize their own
russian people
i have to do a lot of thinking to try to
understand what i even feel i i don't
know but
in terms of information the thing that
the soldiers are saying the the russian
soldiers are saying the thing the
russian soldiers really believe
is that they're freeing they're
liberating
the ukrainian people
from
[Music]
nazis
and they believe this
because i visited ukraine i spoke to
the over 100
probably a couple hundred ukrainian
people from different walks of life
it feels like the russian
soldiers at least are under a cloud of
propaganda
they're not operating on a clear view of
the whole world
and
given all that i just don't
see
russia taking the south
without committing
war crimes
and if vladimir putin is aware of what's
happening in terms of the treatment of
civilians
i don't see
him pushing forward all the way to take
the south
because that's not going to be
effective strategy for him
to
win the hearts and minds of his people
autocracies don't need to win hearts and
minds that's a staunchly democratic
point of view
hearts and minds mean very little to
people who understand core
basic
needs and
uh
and
true power you don't see xi jinping
worrying about hearts and minds in china
you don't see
you don't see it in north korea you
don't see it in
in congo you don't see it in most of the
world hearts and minds are a luxury
in reality what people need is food
water power they need
income to be able to secure a lifestyle
it's
it is absolutely sad i am not in any way
shape or
form
saying that my
assessment on this is
is enriching or enlightening or or uh
hopeful
it's just
fact it's just calculatable empirical
evidence
if putin loses in ukraine the losses the
influential losses the economic losses
the lives lost the power lost is too
great
so it is better for him
to push and push and push through war
crimes through everything else war
crimes are something defined by the
international court system the
international court system has russia as
part of its board
and the international court system is
largely powerless
outs when it comes to enforcing its own
outcomes so the real risk gains scenario
here for for russia
is
is
is significantly in favor of gain over
risk
the other thing that i think is
important to talk about is we
everybody
is trapped in the middle of a gigantic
information war yes there's battlefield
bullets and cannons and tanks but
there's also a massive informational war
the same
narrative that you see
these
ground troops in ukraine these russian
ground troops in ukraine believing
they're clearing the land of nazis
that information is being fed to them
from their own home country
i don't know why people seem to think
that the information that they're
reading in english is any more or less
true
the enti every piece of news coming out
of the west every piece of information
coming out in the english language is
also a giant narrative
being
shared intentionally to try to undermine
the morale and the faithfulness of
english-speaking russians which somebody
somewhere knows exactly how many of
those there are
so we have to recognize that we're not
getting true information from other side
because there is a strategic value in
making sure that there is just the right
amount of miss or disinformation out
there not because someone's trying to
lie to americans but because someone is
trying to influence the way
english-speaking russians think
and in that world that's exactly why you
see so many news articles cited to
anonymous sources
government officials who do not want to
be named there's no nothing that links
back responsibility there right there's
nothing that can go to court there
but this the information still gets
released and that's that's enough to
make ukrainians believe
that the united states is going to help
them or that the west is going to help
them it's enough to make russians think
that that they're going to lose and
maybe they should just un they should
just give up now and leave from the
battlefield now we have to understand we
are in the middle of a giant information
war
maybe you can correct me but it feels
like in the english-speaking world it's
harder to control
it's harder to fight the information war
because of
you know some people say there's not
really a freedom of speech in this
country but i think
if you compare there's a lot more
freedom of speech and it's just harder
to control narratives when there's a
bunch of
um
guerrilla journalists that are able to
just publish anything they want on
twitter or anything it's just harder to
control narratives so people don't
understand what freedom of speech is
that's the first major problem and it's
it's shameful how many people in the
united states do not understand what
freedom of speech actually protects
so
that aside you're absolutely right
fighting the information war in the west
is extremely difficult
because
anyone with a blog anyone with a twitter
account anyone i mean anyone can call
themselves a journalist essentially we
live in a world we live in a country
where people read the headline and they
completely bypass the author line and
they go straight into the content and
then they decide whether the content's
real or not based on how they feel
instead of based on empirical measurable
evidence
so you mentioned the lon lease act
and the support of the united states
support of ukraine by the united states
are you skeptical to the level of
support that the united states is
providing and is going to provide
over over time the strategy the united
states has taken to support ukraine is
similar to the strategy we took to
support great britain during world war
ii
uh the the enactment of the lend lease
act is a perfect example of that the
lend lease act means that we are lending
or releasing equipment to the ukrainian
government in exchange for future
payment
so every time a rocket is launched every
time a drone crashes into a tank that's
that's a bill
that ukraine is
is just racking up it's like when you go
to a restaurant you start drinking shots
sometime the bill will come due
this is exactly what we did when
europe and when great britain was in the
face of
nazi invasion we signed the same thing
into motion do you know that that the uk
did not pay off the debt from world war
ii until 2020.
they've been paying that debt
since the end of world war ii so what
we're doing is we're indebting ukraine
against the promise that perhaps they
will secure their freedom which nobody
seems to want to talk about what freedom
is actually going to look like for
ukrainians right what are the true
handful of outcomes the realistic
outcomes that could come of this and
what which of those outcomes really
looks like freedom to them
especially in the face of the fact that
they're going to be
trillions of dollars in debt to the west
for supplying them with the training and
the weapons and the food and the med
kits and everything else that we're
giving them because none of it's free
it's all coming due it's all we're a
democracy but we're also
a capitalist country we we can't afford
to just give things away for free but we
can give things away at a discount we
can give things away layaway but the
bill will come due and unfortunately
that is not part of the conversation
that's being had with the american
people so debt is a way
to establish some level of control power
is power
that said
having a very
close relationship between ukraine and
the united states does not seem to be
a negative possibility
when ukrainians think about their future
in terms of freedom that's one thing and
the other there's some aspect of this
war that i've just noticed that um one
of the people i talked to said that uh
all great nations
uh have a
independence war they have to have a war
for their independence in order there's
something it's dark but there's
something about
war
just being a catalyst for finding your
own identity as a nation so you can have
leaders you can have sort of signed
documents you can have all this kind of
stuff but there's something about war
that really brings the country together
and actually tried to figure out what is
at the core of the spirit of the people
that defines this country and
they see this war
as that as the independence war to
define the heart of what the country is
so there's a there's been before the war
before this invasion
there was a lot of factions in the
country there was um
a lot of uh influence from oligarchs and
corruption and so on a lot of that was
the factions were brought together under
one umbrella uh effectively to become
one nation because of this invasion so
they see that as a positive
direction for
the
defining of what a free
democratic country looks like after the
war at in their perspective after the
wars won
it's a difficult situation because
i'm trying to make sure that that you
and all everybody listening understands
that
what's happening in ukraine among
ukrainians is noble and brave and
courageous and
beyond the expectations of
anyone
the fact is
there is no material support coming from
the outside the american in the american
revolution was one
because of french involvement french
ships french troops french generals
french military might
the
independence of
of communist china was won
through russian support russian generals
russian troops on the ground fighting
with the communists that's how
revolutions are won that's how
independent countries are born ukraine
doesn't get any of that
no one is stepping into that
because
we live in a world right now
where there simply is no economic
benefits to the parties in power to
support ukraine to that level and
war is a game of economics
the economic benefit of ukraine
is crystal clear
in favor of russia which is why putin
cannot lose he will not let himself lose
uh short of something completely
unexpected
right i'm talking 60 70 probability
ukraine loses but there's still 20 30
probability of the unimaginable
happening
who knows what that might be an oligarch
assassinates putin or a nuclear bomb
goes off somewhere or who knows what
right
there's still a chance that something
unexpected will happen and change the
tide of the war but when it comes down
to
the core calculus here
ukraine is the agricultural bed to
support a future russia
russia knows
they know they have to have ukraine they
know that they have to have it to
protect themselves against military
pressure from the west they have to have
it for agricultural reasons they have
major
oil
and natural gas pipelines that flow
through
eastern ukraine they they cannot let
ukraine fall
outside of their sphere of influence
they cannot
the united states
doesn't really have any economic vested
interest in ukraine ideologics you know
ideological points of view and promises
aside there's no economic benefit and
the same thing goes for nato nato has no
economic investment in ukraine ukrainian
output ukrainian uh
food goes to the middle east and africa
it doesn't go to europe
so the whole
the side the west siding with ukraine is
exclusively ideological and it's putting
them in a place where they fight a war
with russia so the whole world can see
russia's capabilities ukraine is a
it's sad as it is to say man ukraine is
a pawn on a table
for super powers to calculate each
other's capacities
right now we've only talked about russia
in the united states we haven't even
talked about iran we haven't even talked
about china right it is a pawn on a
table this is a chicken fight so that
people get to watch and see what the
other trainers are doing
well a lot of people might have said the
same thing about the united states back
in the independence fight so
there is there is possibilities as
you've said
we're not
uh saying zero percent chance and it
could be a reasonably high percent
chance that this becomes one of the
great democratic nations that the 21st
century is remembered by absolutely and
so um
you said
american support so ideologically first
of all
you don't assign much
long-term
power to that
that us could support ukraine purely on
ideological grounds
just look in the last four years the
last three years do you remember what
happened in hong kong right before kovid
china swooped into hong kong
violently
beating protesters killing them in the
street imprisoning people without just
without just cause and hong kong was a
democracy
and the whole world stood by and let it
happen and then what happened in
afghanistan just a year ago
and the whole world stood by and let the
taliban take power again after 20 years
of loss
this we are showing a repeatable
point of view we will talk american
politicians american administrations we
will say a lot of things we will promise
a lot of ideological pro-democracy ra ra
statements we will say it
but when it comes down to putting our
own people our own economy our own gdp
at risk
we step away from that fight
america is currently supplying
military equipment to ukraine absolutely
and a lot of that military equipment has
actually been the thing that turned the
tides of war a couple of times already
currently that's the haimar systems
so you mentioned sort of
putin can't afford to lose
but winning can look a different way so
you've kind of defined so on
at this moment
the prediction is that winning looks
like capturing not just the east
but the south of ukraine
but
you could have narratives of winning
that returned back to the
uh what was at the beginning of this
year before the invasion correct that
crimea
is still with russia
there's some kind of negotiated thing
about donbass where it still stays with
ukraine but there's some
puppet government yeah yeah just like
that's what they have in georgia right
now
and that could still be defined through
mechanisms
as russia winning as russia winning for
russia and then for ukraine as ukraine
winning
uh and and for the west as uh democracy
winning and you kind of negotiate i mean
that seems to be how
geopolitics works is everybody can walk
away with a win-win story and then the
world progresses
with the lessons learned that's the high
likely that's the most probable outcome
the most probable outcome is that
ukraine remains
in air quotes a sovereign nation
it's not going to be truly sovereign
because it will become
it will uh have to have new government
put in place
zielinski will it's extremely unlikely
he will be president
because he has gone too far to
demonstrate his
power over the people and his ability to
separate the ukrainian people from the
autocratic power of russia so he would
have to be
unseated whether he goes into exile
or whether he is peacefully left alone
is all gonna be part of negotiations but
the thing the thing to keep in mind also
is that a negotiated peace really just
means a negotiated ceasefire we've seen
this happen all over the world north
korea and south korea are technically
still just in negotiated cease power
what you end up having is
russia will allow
ukraine to call itself ukraine to
operate independently to have their own
debt to the united states russia doesn't
want to take on that debt
and then
in exchange for that they will have
firmer guidelines as to how nato can
engage with ukraine and then that
becomes an example for all the other
former soviet satellite states which are
all required economically
by russia not required economically by
the west
and then you end up seeing how it just
you can see how the whole thing plays
out once you realize that the keystone
is ukraine
there is something about ukraine the
deep support by the ukrainian people of
america
that
is in contrast with
for example afghanistan
that
it seems like ideologically ukraine
could be a beacon of freedom used in
narratives by the united states
to fight geopolitical wars in that part
of the world that they would be a good
partner
for this idea of democracy of freedom
of all the values that america stands
for they're a good partner and so it's
valuable
if you sort of have a cynical pragmatic
view sort of like henry kissinger type
of view
it's valuable to have them as a partner
so valuable that it makes sense to
support them
in achieving a negotiated ceasefire
that's on the side of ukraine but
because of this particular leader this
particular culture this particular
dynamics of how the war unrolled and uh
things like twitter and the way digital
communication currently works it just
seems like this is a powerful symbol of
freedom that's useful for the united
states if we're starting to take the
pragmatic
view don't you think it it's possible
that uh united states
supports ukraine financially militarily
enough for it to get an advantage in
this war i think they've already got an
advantage in the war the fact the war is
still going on demonstrates the
asymmetrical advantage the fact that
russia has stepped up to the negotiating
table with them several times
without just
turning to
chechen check i mean remember what
happened in chechnya
without turning to chechnya levels just
mass
blind destruction which was another
putin war
to see that those things have happened
demonstrates the asymmetric advantage
that the west has given i think the
the
true way to look at the benefit of
ukraine as a
shining example of freedom in europe for
the west
isn't to understand whether or not they
could they absolutely could
it's the question of how valuable is
that
in europe how valuable is ukraine which
before
january before february
nobody even thought about ukraine and
the people who did know about ukraine
knew that it was a extremely corrupt
former soviet state
with 20 of its national population
self-identifying as russian
like you there's a reason putin went
into ukraine there's a reason he's been
promising he would go into ukraine for
the better part of a decade
because
the the circumstances were aligned it
was a corrupt country that
self-identified as russian in many ways
it was a it was supposed to be an easier
of multiple marks in terms of the former
soviet satellite states to go after
that's all part of the miscalculation
that the rest of the world saw too
when we thought it would fall quickly
so to think that it could be a shining
shining example of freedom is accurate
but
is it as shining a star as germany is it
as shining a star as the uk is it as
shining a star as romania is it as shiny
as star as
uh as france like
it's got a lot of
democratic freedom-based
countries in europe to compete against
to be
this the shining stellar example and in
exchange on counterpoint to that it has
an extreme amount of strategic value to
russia which has no interest in making
it a shining star of the example of of
democracy and freedom outside of
research in terms of the shininess of
the star i would argue yes if you look
at how much you captivated the intention
of the world the attention the world has
made no material difference man that's
what i'm saying
that's your estimation but you know are
you sure we can
we can't
um if you can convert that into
political influence
into money don't you think attention is
money
attention is money in democracies in
capitalist countries
yes which serves as a counterweight to
sort of authoritarian regimes so for for
putin resources matter the united states
also resources matter but the attention
and
the belief the people also matter
because that's how you attain and
maintain political power this so going
to that exact example
then i would highlight that our current
administration has the lowest approval
ratings of any president in history
so if people were very fond of the war
going on in ukraine wouldn't that
counter balance some of our upset some
of the distant coming from the economy
and some of the dissent coming from from
the the great recession and or the
second great or the great resignation
and whatever's happening with the draw
with the down stock market you would
think that people would feel like
they're sacrificing for something if
they really believed
that ukraine mattered that they would
they would stand next to the president
who is
who is so staunchly driving and leading
the west against this conflict well i
think the opposition to this particular
president
i personally believe has less to do with
the policies and more to do
with
a lot of the other human factors
uh and
but again empirically this is i look at
things through a very empirical lens a
very
a very cold
fact-based lens and there are multiple
data points that suggest that the
american people
ideologically sympathize with ukraine
but they really just want their gas
prices to go down they really just want
to be able to pay less money at the
grocery store for their food and they
most definitely don't want their sons
and daughters
to die in exchange for ukrainian freedom
it does hurt me to see the
politicization of this war as well
i think that has
that's maybe has to do with the kind of
calculation you're referring to
but it seems like it doesn't it seems
like there's a cynical whatever takes
attention of the media for the moment
the the red team chooses one side and
the blue team chooses another
and then um
i think correct me if i'm wrong but i
believe the democrats went into full
like support of ukraine on the ideal
logical side and then i guess
republicans are saying why are we
wasting money the prices are the the gas
prices are going up that's that's a very
crude kind of analysis but they
basically picked whatever argument on
whatever side and now
more and more and more this particular
war in ukraine is becoming
a kind of pawn in the game of politics
that's uh first the midterm elections
then building up towards the
presidential elections and stops being
about
the
philosophical the social the
geopolitical aspects
parameters of this war and more
biologists like whatever the heck
captivates twitter and we're going to
use that for politics you're right in
sense of the fact that it's i wouldn't
say that the red team and the blue team
picked opposite sides on this what i
would say is that
media
discovered that talking about ukraine
wasn't as profitable as talking about
something else
people simply the american people who
read media or who watch media they
simply became
bored reading about news that didn't
seem to be changing much and
we turned back into wanting to read
about our own economy and we wanted to
hear more about cryptocurrency and we
wanted to hear more about the
kardashians and that's that's what we
care about so that's what media writes
about that's how
a capitalist market driven world works
and that's how the united states works
that's why in both red papers and blue
papers red sources and blue sources you
don't see ukraine being mentioned very
much if anything i would say that your
republicans are probably more in support
of what's happening in ukraine right now
because we're creating new weapon
systems our military is getting stronger
we're sending these military we get to
test
military systems in combat
in ukraine that's priceless in the world
of the military the military industrial
complex
being able to field test combat test a
weapon
without having to sacrifice your own
people
is incredibly valuable you get all the
data you get all the performance metrics
but you don't have to put yourself at
risk that is one of the major benefits
of
what we're seeing from supporting
ukraine with weapons and with troops the
long-term benefit to what will come of
this for the united states
practically speaking in the lens of
national security through military
readiness through future economic
benefits those are super strong the
geopolitical fight is is essentially
moot because ukraine is not a
geopolitical player it was not for
for 70 years
and after this conflict is over it will
not again
just think about what you were just
saying with the american people's
attention span to twitter and whatever's
currently going on if the ukraine
conflict resolved itself today
in either in any direction
how many weeks do you think before no
one talked about ukraine anymore do you
think we would make it two weeks do you
think we'd make it maybe seven days it
would be headline news for one or two
days
and then we'd be on to something else
it's just an unfortunate reality
of how the world works in a capitalist
democracy
yeah it just breaks my heart how much
you know i know that there's
yemen and syria and
that nobody talks about anymore still
raging conflicts going on
it just it breaks my heart how much
generational hatred is born
i happen to be from
uh my family is from ukraine and from
russia and so for me just personally
it's a part of the world i care about in
terms of its history i because i speak
the language
i can appreciate the beauty of the
literature the music the art the the
cultural history of the 20th century
through all the dark times
through all the the hell
of
the dark sides of authoritarian regimes
the destruction of war there's still
just the beauty that i'm able to
appreciate that i can't appreciate about
china
brazil
other countries because i don't speak
their language this one i can appreciate
and so
in that way this is personally really
painful to me to see
so much of that history the beauty in
that history suffocated by the hatred
that is born through this kind of
geopolitical
game
uh fought mostly by
the politicians the leaders people are
beautiful and that's what you're talking
about people are just
people are beautiful creatures
culture
and art
and
and science like these are beautiful
beautiful things that come about because
of human beings
and the thing that gives me hope
is that
no matter what conflict the world has
seen and we've seen some devastating
horrible crimes against humanity already
we saw nuclear bombs go off in japan
we saw
we saw genocide happen in rwanda we've
seen horrible things happen but people
persevere
language culture arts science they all
persevere they all shine through
some of the most people don't even
realize how gorgeous the architecture
and the culture is inside iran people
have no idea
chinese people
in the
rural parts of china are some of the
kindest most amazing people you'll ever
meet and korean art and korean dance
korean drumming i know nobody has ever
even heard of korean drumming korean
drumming is this magical beautiful thing
and the north in north korea does it
better than anybody in the world
taekwondo in north korea is just
north korea and north korea
nobody knows these things how do you
know about tycho north korea i have
questions
but that's fascinating that's that's a
like people don't think about that but
the culture the beauty of the people
still flourishes even in the toughest of
times absolutely and we always will we
always will because that is what people
do
and that is that is just the truth of it
and it breaks my heart to see travesties
that people commit against people
but whether you're looking at a micro
level like what happens with shootings
here in the united states or whether you
look at a macro level like geopolitical
power exchanges and
intra and interstate conflicts like what
you see in syria and what you see in
ukraine
those are disgusting terrible things war
is a terrible thing that is a famous
quote
but people
will persevere people will
come through
i hope so i hope so
and i hope we don't do something um
that i'll probably also ask you about
later on is things that
um destroy the possibility of
perseverance which is things like
nuclear war things things that can do
such tremendous
uh damage that we we will never recover
but yeah i i
amidst your pragmatic pessimism
i think both you and i have a kind of
maybe small flame of optimism in there
about the perseverance of the human
species in general
you